[Music]
it was 15 years ago that sam witwicky
teamed up with the autobots to battle
the evil decepticons and michael-based
transformers since then not only has a
lot of time passed but also much has
changed in the movie series in this
video we do not want to take a look into
the future as usual but rather focus on
the past what made the first movie of
the transformers series so special and
why were so many things different after
the third part these are the questions
we will be looking into today and we
hope that we can evoke a bit of
nostalgia as well and perhaps now it is
even the time to re-watch the series
first let's examine how the blockbuster
series came to be in the first place at
the time the decision to make a
transformers movie was not in the hands
of a movie studio but a toy manufacturer
so in the early 2000s the hasbro company
thought about producing a movie for the
gi joe toy series however with the
outbreak of the iraq war they decided
not to and went for hasbro's second most
popular brand the transformers the theme
met with a widespread approval and so in
2003 dreamworks and paramount began with
the film's production due to the
popularity of the brand especially among
children steven spielberg was quickly
hired as executive producer while
michael bay took over the directing
actually he had no interest in making a
movie about children's toys however
after hasbro personally approached him
and assured that he could also make the
film accessible to an adult audience he
finally agreed and so the team was
complete in march 2006 the first actor
namely xiao above was confirmed and
filming began that same year alongside
sony's spider-man series with toby
maguire transformers marked the big
start of comic book adaptions in the
2000s despite the fact that they didn't
originate from marvel which as we know
didn't really get going until 2008 with
the release of iron man since hasbro
naturally wanted to turn a profit from
their transformers project the producers
had to work out the name and design of
the transformers well before filming
began in order for the toy giant to go
into pre-production as a result the
movie ended up featuring autobots and
decepticons which never made an
appearance in the transformers comics
the experienced star wars crew at
industrial light and magic was tasked
with bringing the robots to life on the
computer the transformers were so
detailed and complex that it took
islam's animators 38 hours to fit them
into a single frame of the film after
black hawk down and hulk transformers
was also just the third film in the 21st
century to use footage from the us air
force the film was shot at the holloman
air force base and the white sands
missile range it was well worth it as
the movie grossed more than 700 million
us dollars thus paving the way for the
big franchise in addition to stars like
shia labeouf megan fox and joshua ml
peter cullen was cast as the voice actor
for optimus prime he had already dubbed
the leader of the autobots in the
animated series from the 80s and 90s
but what plot did the creators come up
with for the big screen appearance first
let's have a brief overview of the
history of the planet cybertron which
was home to a race of intelligent
machine creatures with the ability to
transform their bodies into other forms
once optimus prime and megatron ruled
the planet together however megatron
wanted to rule over the entire universe
as a result there was a battle between
the autobots and the decepticons
megatron was after the all spark a
cube-shaped artifact that had once given
life for the machines on cybertron the
autobots knew they had no chance of
winning so they launched the old spark
into space it landed on earth as did
some autobots and decepticons years
later young samwit wiki finally gets his
own car from his parents with this car
he wants to impress michaela a teenage
girl from a school even though he's not
completely satisfied with it at first he
is so astonished his car is in fact an
alien named bumblebee who has long been
hiding on earth it turns out that the
location of the old spark is burned into
the glasses of sam's great-grandfather
100 years ago he had found both the
all-spark and megatron in the eyes
bumblebee notifies his audubon allies
but not only they learn of sam's fine so
do the decepticons thus a battle against
the clock begins with sam and his
beloved mikhail at the center of it all
it becomes especially dangerous for
everyone when megatron awakens from his
hibernation and the decepticons present
themselves to humans for the first time
in millennia
at the time the film had everything a
successful action movie needed cars
robots explosions and of course a bit of
bare skin presented here by megan fox
but what also stands out is the
heroization of the used military this
was not well received by the press given
that the crimes of the iraq war were
slowly but surely being dealt with
during this time worth mentioning is the
final battle in the fictional place
mission city in which the military
fights together with the autobots such
scenes are consistently backed with
heroic music and lots of bursts in spite
of heavy criticism from the press in the
second part also in the final battle in
the desert the creators went the extra
mile within a few minutes the military
manages to attack the decepticons on
international soil with air and naval
units and land forces again of course
with dramatic music and lots of
explosions a scenery which at that time
caused us to get goosebumps and which
conveyed the feeling that america is
strong and ready at all times it's easy
to forget that reality looks a little
different transformers therefore
naturally offered a flawless and
entertaining distraction from everyday
life and thus perhaps exactly what the
audience wanted but the glorification of
the military is not the only thing that
will always be associated with the
transformers franchise
due to the big popularity of the first
film sequels were of course inevitable
the second part was still very
reminiscent of the previous one but then
came the first major change in the movie
series megan fox announced that she was
no longer willing to take on the role of
michaela primarily because she was not
happy with the way her character was
being used stylistically in keeping with
the motto's sex cells she was in fact
mostly busy showing herself of scantily
dressed and provocative poses in the
first two parts which was a reason for
her to drop out after two films however
she was not the last person to leave the
movie series after the third installment
almost the entire cast left chalebev
immediately announced that he would
devote himself to his role in the
indiana jones franchise in the future
well
we know how that turned out just your
melon the rest of the cast likewise
looked for new opportunities anyway they
did manage to find a popular new face
for transformers in mark wahlberg
although the fourth film was not well
received by all fans so josh uml john
totoro and tyrese gibson were brought
right back into the team even julie
white returned to play the role of judy
with wiki what other role sam's mother
will play however is not entirely clear
yet a spin-off film for bumblebee
followed in 2018 the sixth part of the
main series was already confirmed in
2019 but due to the pandemic the release
was postponed to 2023 we have also made
an original about transformers rise of
the beasts so if you want to know more
about that now just follow the link at
the end of this video a further
transformers movie has also already been
announced for the year 2025 however
there is no title for it yet
well that was everything regarding the
transformers movies for many fans at the
time the first film was something that
movie theaters had never witnessed
before even before marvel's and dc
superheroes drew large crowds to the
movies optimus prime and his team were
already protecting the world thereby
paving the way for all other comic book
adaptions loud colorful and big that was
their motto and despite all the
criticism the series has received over
the years this promise was always kept
how do you view it what are your
thoughts on how the movie series has
evolved are you looking forward to the
sequel of the blockbuster series and
above all what do the transformers mean
to you today are they just a fun child
of memory or are they still the kind of
entertainment a visit to the cinema
needs let us know what your opinion is
in the comments and be sure to check out
our videos solely on transformers rise
of the beasts see you next time
[Music]
you